and I was like mom you let me go to camp
all gay kids like that's dream what do
you mean sounds like thank you that
hello what's up dude
good good poor you guys hi I'm Michael
hi I'm Zack where the star is
ding - I'm Zack I think one because I
was born first before we came out we
were still casts prior to being might be
gay Arabs we were put in specialized
classes together we had a really bad
speech appointment we all have no
friends in middle school we were both
still in special ed so that's what
people saw me I think you thought we
were Bob Euler and then you look at it
like four years later you're like wow us
I only have like one hint that Michael
was gay after I did things would like
pinch the kid was like hey brothers like
kind of being like funny like okay like
really gay and I was like not Michael
I'm the gay one in my head I didn't I
didn't even like put two and two
together I was just so focused on my own
shirt and I was always kind of mild Zach
got hot getting a [ __ ] and that was
the rumor around school and I was like
I'm so unpopular no one even thinks it's
me well I'm just doing short we both got
a [ __ ] from the same kid and
accidentally boys and girls didn't
really clean I never thought actually
until I got trapped from my first
relationship with a different set of
twins our girls I ended up having sex
with her 10th grade I made out with the
captain of the basketball team
I ain't big and then it makes that I was
trying to run for Student Council the
time trying to gain my popularity that
one like Sharpedo over my bill disturb
fake Terrence so I was like I'm not a
mutant counts bullying us for being
special I had their willingness for
being terrorists now they're boiling us
for being gay so you know i mean the
whole slew of being bullied so i think
we had to rely on each other's closeness
because it was the only way to make that
situation fun or make mine that old
buddies coming out what is being labeled
now
our family they're both 100% Chaldean
and to the photo don't know that
basically Christian Iraq and Krishna are
a Kubica Middle East from Baghdad our
family came here during the Detroit
riots and seventies my mom and my dad
both got bullied because they didn't
speak English they were like presumed
wife till I got bullied a lot and I
think that affected a lot more your own
childhood my mom's like don't talk to
anyone here I'm gonna bully you and you
know what they did my mom knew that Zack
worked at a gay coffee shop but didn't
think that he was gay that was the first
red flag no no the first red flag just
with her 14-inch ambadas and being said
she said you guys guys are so creative
is the creative I got you a jewellery
set my hand nothing about Barbie nothing
that affected me but hey I feel like
come on she knew mom's dark shirt around
18 she confronted me ask you you know
why all your prints girls and I said I
was like what do you mean she's like
tell me you're not I know what you're
like getting excited she couldn't say
the word she gets it she I base was like
I think I am I couldn't even look at her
but I think I am and she's like you
think you are what I am you know she
goes yeah so she goes upstairs i text
michael she knows I know I deal this
like three years later so I like go to
the stairs like mom
Michael too it's just god damn it okay
we never had to write a book or coming
out or come out but our mom was in
everything for us this is what inspired
the book this I was like whoa mom when
it's been trying to try to get away from
the last year that's funny
let's look our mom threw holy water on
us after week now it all happened this
like one night and she wants to get our
knees Michaels we got our knees and she
made us recite Hail Mary in Arabic
and as she was doing this she was
recording up her little self but was
recording on her opponent during my
water and two weeks later while we were
sleeping she crawls in our bed and tries
to DK us with holy grapes and forced
three of them in my mouth and I was
blessed by enough I was like mom why are
you recording this
I needed leverage so bad that you guys
are good Christian and we can get him to
heaven but I mean to her it was like
Cheryl she was protecting us Dallas it
was a global person I was like here
honestly if I didn't have between my
coming-out experience could have been
totally different whereas me and Michael
together we kinda laptop you have to
understand your parents are still at all
and them it's confusing you're growing
your new shell they're growing to find
your new shell comfortable under the day
we're all still people and I beg people
don't realize that you know like we say
like immigrants are like well hot why
are immigrants lesser than a normal
person
why the hell are a people I need
difference in the strippers you know we
always hope for look at the back
knowledge we don't care for one another
and that's I think I'd love that
syphilis
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part